all right welcome back to Hannity our
red state blue State debate uh by mutual
agreement uh both candidates had other
commitments and they realized afterwards
they couldn't stay longer uh but we
appreciate them all being here tonight
okay what did you think about it was
there a winner Loser winners losers you
get to react anyway here joining us
co-host of the five and former
Democratic Congressman Harold Ford Jr
along with the co-host of outnumbered
Kaye mckinin Fox News contributor AR fer
Kaylee we start with you that was a very
low energy debate that's my first
observation uh and mine was the opposite
I know you're being fous what an
edifying constructive smart hour with
fact-based questions Sean one of the
best events I've seen in a very long
time so well done on your part look in
press as when I was press secretary Ari
knows this you ask yourself do you have
a fax problem or do you have a messaging
problem and tonight what you saw was a
fax problem for Gavin Nome you put up
the numbers they were undeniable you
sourced them and what the public saw was
the sharpest best messenger in the
Democrat Party I maintain that's Gavin
Nome unable to message the rotting pile
of facts before him both in the state of
California and nationally for Joe Biden
DeSantis had some really strong moments
particularly when he said look I talked
to a guy who said I love the the
employment down here I love the wages
down here I I love the State of Florida
how safe it is oh by the way that was
your father in-law Gavin Nome also
pulling out the map of the the feces in
San Francisco another strong and
powerful moment so I think the clear
winner Ronda santis and a nearly
impossible task for Gavin
Newsome let's get your take uh Ari
fler well I I think watching this you
just realize Democrats Are from Mars and
Republicans are from Venus I mean they
speak totally different languages Ronda
sanz's language was one of economics
gasoline $67 a gallon the lockdowns in
California it was very practical very
focused on people's daily lives the
riseing cost of living if you listen to
Gavin Newsome his whole message was
identity politics which is the language
of the Democrats I don't like the way
you talk about migrants we have to fight
for women everything he says is about a
group an ethnic group a chunk of
Americans it's not about America and
that's the language the Democrats
respond to so you really have two
different approaches for what America
needs I will say this Gavin Nome is much
more articulate fast on his feet and
sharper than Joe Biden and if I'm a
Democrat looking at the presidential
race even if I dismiss Ronda santis I
have to still worry about Joe Biden and
that's a difference in a in just Biden's
age Sean as you pointed that out the
final thing I'll say about D santis I
don't think that he closed the Gap with
Donald Trump tonight it was a nice night
for him and he did well and he had had
the facts on his side but when you look
at the purpose of him being there which
is to win a presidential race I just
don't think he closed the
Gap actually it was separate from that I
could just tell you in the discussion
leading up to this that this was really
State versus State and um although
clearly I think gin at times wanted to
talk more presidential politics uh
Harold Ford Jr your
take so first off congrats Sean I
thought you did a great job and you
framed this thing the right way a state
versus estate and both of these
candidates uh who were Governors were
very passionate patriotic they defended
their records uh I think kayy and and um
Mr fer right I think what Ari said at
the end there is probably most useful
and maybe the utility level is highest
um who did best for their parties T
night I think one of the things and
Kaylee said at the outset there's no
doubt that Gavin new will be the most
important the most forceful and
articulate uh uh Advocate on on behalf
of Democrats in this 2024 election and
Governor Dan santis I think displayed
one of the things that Republicans going
to have to deal with how do you talk
about the economy how do you talk about
issues in the face of I think whether we
like it or not or agree or not one of
the most powerful issues in this
election in 2024 is going to be this
issue of reproductive rights for women
uh it's not going to overtake everything
but will certainly be one of the most
important issues and I think where we
are 6 months from today with regard to
gas prices and inflation will probably
determine more about the outcome of the
presidential race than anything else but
as it relates to the state issues
Florida California I got to tell you I
was more impressed with Ronda Sanz than
I thought I would be I thought that
Governor Nome who I think is one of the
most uh effective presenters in politics
he was that tonight but I thought that
Governor Des Sanz laid out very
effectively his record in Florida was it
able to uh do what he wanted to do on
the presid presidential stage probably
not but tonight I think he probably
fared better than I thought a lot of
people thought he might have fared
against a guy in our party uh Gavin
Newsome who I thought did well tonight
but I thought Governor Dan santis uh did
a pretty good job tonight as well too
defending his State and his
record what did you think kayy about the
answer when I quoted LBJ uh in terms of
Gavin there's a lot of Suspicion a lot
of people around the country polls are
bearing this out now more than ever
that people are seeing Joe Biden as as
weak and frail and in cognitive decline
um that was not something that gin
Newsome wanted to admit but when you
bring up the issue of whether or not if
his party came to him whether he's he's
been very clear in all three interviews
that I've had with him tonight being a
debate obviously I'm moderating but that
it he thinks that it would be the vice
president vice president Harris and not
him up next um
if you say it that often I I you have to
take somebody at their word don't
you well as a political figure there are
certain things you have to say this is
why every single person probably in all
of time who has run for President says
oh no you know it's not my time I'm not
thinking of that right now I'm focusing
on my state my city Etc and then several
of them go on to run for president there
are certain things that you must say
Gavin Newsome tonight must have said
over and over again it's Joe Biden and
then given that head to KLA Harris but
what I look at are what were the words
of Gavin Nome leading into the midterm
elections days before the midterm
elections he talked about his
fundamental grievances with their with
his party they're unable to message it
was someone by his words that seemed to
be clearly posturing in the event of a
red wave either running himself and
taking on Joe Biden or being the second
alternative waiting in the wings then
the Red Wave didn't happen it crashed
and burned and all of a sudden Gavin
Nome kissed the the ring and says yes
it's you Joe Biden you had a very good
midterm election I think he's waiting in
the wings he can't get on the ballot
because we've missed several ballot
deadlines but I think he's waiting in
the event that something goes wrong at
the Democratic party at the Democratic
National Convention where they actually
Nam the nominee he's waiting there
that's the only reason that you do a
debate like what we saw tonight going
toe-to-toe with someone who is running
himself to be the GOP
nominee exit quick grade that's it um
Ari will start with with you how would
you grade Governor Dan santis tonight
and what grade would you give Gavin Nome
tonight I'd give Dan santis a B+ in the
way he handled the facts I would give
him a B minus because he hardly ever
looked Gavin new in the eye and if
you're going to be strong you need to
look your opponent in the eye he did it
occasionally you need to do it always I
would give n a d uh just in terms of his
mangling of the facts his fabricating
his making things up in terms of being
glib yeah i' give him an a I I don't
think I've ever seen a guy standing the
on Deck Circle putting pinear on his Bat
studying the pitcher and swinging the
bat all the while denying that he's
going to step up to the plate that's
what Gavin new was tonight har Harold
Ford Jr
grades I give them both B pluses I
thought they did what they had to do
tonight to try to advance where they
were uh I do think that if you're
Governor Haley if you're thinking about
the presidential race tonight uh
Governor Haley probably is feeling fine
tonight and I think in the in the
presidential race uh former president
Trump is f probably feeling a much much
better and if you're President Biden you
better sign Governor Nome up to be your
uh Chief surrogate uh in this
presidential race kayy you get the last
word
great DeSantis gets an a he was the
clear runaway winner however Gavin
Newsome given the bad pile of facts gets
a c he's a sharp messenger watch out
that guy's coming uh he's a rising star
in the
party all right thanks all three I
appreciate it uh thanks for being with
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else